My English is not so good but I’m gonna
explain...
This was 26th May, just 10 days or a week
ago.
I made this performance all by myself,
and I was collaborating with a violinist
he’s playing now.
He’s from Berliner Philharmonie and he composed
this music for me
but I think he was very inspired by Japan
and Asia
so he made this music, and then
this is my shadow, I’m behind.
And then this picture I took in Tokyo somewhere
in April.
So I was doing this behind
with this music
and this was the world premier of the performance
in Osaka.
And I also did this performance in Berlin,
Germany
in Berliner Philharmonie, officially.
This is like winter, but my imagination was
like Japanese birds in snow.
That was my image.
The costume I also created.
I designed and made it.
So this is kind of like I was doing bird but
also like bird.
I’m dancing with ballet shoes, which is
not point shoes.
Point shoes is one where I stand on the point.
This is the second act already.
The first act I was trying to do visually
like using projectors, photos and dance.
This is like the section that has jazz and
tango with high heels.
And I'm a classic ballet dance, but now I'm
trying to do everything
now I know how to do everything.
Also the company I was dancing with in Germany
I had to do everything, like contemporary,
classic.
And my mom's a pianist, so she's playing.
I was born with a musical family.
My father is a clarinetist, my mother is a
pianist.
And if I had a sponsor and big budget I wanted
to use big mirrors
and also hanging on top
but I couldn't manage it, that's all I could
do.
Because I did it all by myself for this one.
I had limited budget and possibility, and
also technology.
And this is my father.
This performance was kind of a thank you to
my parents too.
Because I left Japan 23 years ago
and I've been living 23 years by myself without
my parents
and I don't see them so often
so I invited them to play with me
This is me also with the wig.
It's a little bit of a joke.
This is Bach, one of the most famous classical
composers.
I was trying to make something out of Bach,
it's very difficult.
I also did a collaboration with a cellist,
David Geringas.
He's also very famous.
But Bach is very, very challenging.
This is not the final one, because every day
I hear music and some new idea comes up.
And...
This isn't final but I had to do something
on the 26th so I did this.
But I had more ideas which I couldn't do.
I wanted to dance on top of the air
and have something like hanging or something,
but...
I didn't have the possibility.
So I was just dancing to this.
And this is like...
This is music from Thai meditation.
I was trying to do like...
This was kind of like I lost hope.
For dancing, and life, and everything in the
beginning.
And I found the point shoes.
Which was my dream when...
I remember that time.
I tried to...
dance.
This was my...
I don't know if people understood or not.
So this performance I made 3 parts.
First is visual, like Japanese, a little Asian.
Second part was jazz, tap, tango
and third, this is the classic part.
And the last one I danced to Swan, which is
my roots.
So I will tell my... this is the swan.
But in the ballet world it's called the dying
swan.
Swan's dying.
One of the very famous solos for females.
Which...
So this was a week ago...
that I made it, but...
I studied ballet in Moscow at Bolshoi Ballet.
It was like '91 when I first went there.
At that time it was still like the Soviet
Union, between, you know, the changing period.
I saw everything, like bombing, a car going
and all this.
There was no food.
And shooting all over.
And drunk pupils laying down in the street.
And I was 13 when I first went there.
And when I was 15 I... yeah, that was high
school.
I left Japan alone.
At that time, of course I was just talking
with, Google was 19 years, like you know....
Yeah?
So it was like '93 when I first left.
Of course no internet, no cell phone.
I only had the possibility to write a letter.
But it was too cold in the dormitory, so there
was no heating.
No food, and I was thinking...
But it must be like this to do something like,
you know...
That I want to be a ballerina and know how
to do this.
That was my start.
So I was writing letters every week sending
to my mother.
And 2 months later I get letters from my mom.
Like every week I get some story from 2 months
ago.
When Gorbachev, if you remember Gorbachev,
when he went out and Yeltsin came
I couldn't go out of my dormitory, I was 2
months almost kidnapped
so I couldn't write a letter
and my mother was thinking, "Maybe I can't
see my daughter again" because...
Anyway, that was my start.
Doing ballet.
Just ballet.
It was very strict.
After graduating Bolshoi I went to...
No, actually I was dancing in Moscow stiil,
but I thought,
it's too difficult because I got only $80
a month for salary.
It's like nothing.
But at that time the real estate business
was starting in Russia.
So I had to pay like $200 a month to rent
a room
Everybody had like free apartments and stuff
like that, but I didn't so I had to pay.
So I was thinking I get like $80 and I pay
$200 for my apartment.
I can't continue because I didn't wanna get
help from my parents.
I didn't want that, so...
So I was thinking to do an audition tour.
But first I wanted to compete in an international
competition in Paris
and I went to Paris alone.
And then I just opened my eyes!
Wow, it's beautiful!
The food is delicious!
What is this?
So beautiful, everything.
So I was thinking maybe I have to leave Russia.
It's too much for me.
I was thinking I had to do it, but maybe there's
another world...
So I started touring.
My audition tour.
Now it's very easy.
I search a company and there's so much information.
Applications you send in seconds.
Photos, resume, finish.
But I had to search by magazines.
Telephone number, calling, no answer.
Sending photos takes one week.
Get it or not, you don't know.
So that was that time.
So anyway, I had to go.
So I bought one-way ticket to Berlin.
Why Berlin?I don't know.
It was the cheapest I could find.
So I went to Berlin.
Starting I went to a company, that I danced
with 10 years later,
but the director was not there, so I couldn't
audition.
That was my first audition.
So I was like, "Wow, OK!"
So I searched the next day...
Munich audition.
I decided to go.
I bought a train ticket and went to Munich.
That was a cool audition.
10 year old kids auditioning.
So that was my second audition.
It's very difficult to get a job.
It's still difficult, but I had a dream to
be a ballerina,
so I want to do everything by myself.
So I went all over the place and saving money,
so I was taking night trains
going all around Switzerland, ended up in
London.
England.
I went to Dover over in the ferry.
So I came back 3 weeks later
My company I was dancing with in Moscow, I
told them 3 days
I wouldn't come for 3 days.
So 3 weeks later I came back, and I was OK.
Moscow and the company, I'm very thankful.
Of course, I was not fired.
But the next year I went to Germany.
That tour I got two contracts.
That auditioning tour.
So I went to Germany, but that was...
But that was not what I want to do, it was
too contemporary.
Now I do everything like this, but I was studying
in Russia and it was pure classic.
Only classic.
I was thinking ballet it just point shoes,
Swan Lake and that's it.
In Germany it's very advanced.
But you have to dance barefoot or naked or
with projector.
I was like, "Wow!"
I couldn't enjoy that.
It was too new for me.
I was also kind of homesick, because in Germany
the pupils work, finish, go home, and that's
it.
And Russia of course it's money, no money,
whatever, but the pupils are always together.
Helping each other.
At that time especially.
It was very warm.
I didn't have money or anything, but I was
very happy always.
And I was very warm.
I think that was the art power.
And in Germany of course I got monthly pay
But I was thinking "Why am I doing this?"
Because I was not happy, and after work I
go home alone.
And doing nothing.
So I started thinking maybe I have to find
the next step.
This is not my place.
So I went to do a competition in America
because I learned it's faster to go to competition
and meet everybody
than going one place, the next place...
So I went to the competition...
not...
thinking about getting something, but meeting
pupils there, getting contacts, and maybe
get a new idea or possibility.
So that competition had one director and he
gave me a contract.
I didn't get any prize.
I was a finalist.
But I got an offer from America.
So I was thinking for 2 days, calling my mom
asking "What do you think?"
"Shall I try or not?"
And my mom and my father
"I don't know!
You know better!"
"So you decide!"
That was my parents.
So one day I think, if I don't try at this
moment, maybe I'll never have the chance again.
Because if I go to the audition in America
and don't get it, so I was thinking,
OK, I'll try.
So I went back to Germany
got everything, send the suitcase
and in 2 months I was in America.
Indianapolis.
So I danced in Indianapolis, and the next
year my big dream was dancing Swan Lake full
rank.
Odette and Odile, there's two swans, white
and black.
That was one of my dreams.
But the Indianapolis dance company was only
25 dancers.
It was not possible.
So I went to audition and got a contract in
Cleveland San Jose Ballet
where I could dance Swan Lake.
I invited my parents
to say thank you, and that was a very touching
moment for me.
But the company went bankrupt the next year
American ballet company was almost...
The budget was by sponsors.
Something didn't go well and that's it.
Very dangerous.
Germany is the government supporting it.
But it went bankrupt so I had to find a new
job.
So I went to San Jose California for one year.
And after Boston for two years.
And then when I was at Boston
September 11th happened.
11 pupils got fired a week later.
It was very, very dangerous moment for everybody.
Dangerous means no activity.
The people didn't go out.
Just stayed at home.
Our business, the show business, if there's
no audience the show doesn't go on.
So I was thinking this is also...
Pupils only talk about money.
And I'm not dancing for money only.
And I was thinking maybe I have to leave America.
And I was thinking my first audition I couldn't
do was in Berlin.
Maybe I have to go back to Berlin.
Because at that time of course you don't know
but
there was a world wide star dancer.
Very famous.
He was going to take over Berlin ballet.
As one big company.
Berlin had three companies.
Staatsoper, Deutsche Oper and Komische Oper
because
of the wall.
West Berlin and East Berlin.
It was separated.
They had like three companies but tried to
make it one big company.
It was 2004.
They did a very big audition worldwide.
So I went there because I thought maybe I
have to do this audition and finish my career.
Because I couldn't do it when I was 19.
Then I was 25.
But then he gave me a contract in Berlin.
So I think...
It was 2004 and I was starting dancing 10
years with the Berlin Staatsballett.
Which is very stable, because every month
I get paid
No matter if I'm sick or injured
and it was a very nice time
I liked my after work time.
That's why I now do collaborations.
I went to Philharmony opera and met lots of
interesting artists, painters and...
Architects.
Like, how to say...
Technicians.
But like projector techniques.
So I was collaborating with very interesting
technical pupils.
Did a performance in a swimming pool.
Or stations or churches.
And very important thing as an artist
there's no limit, or no end, because I have
like new ideas every day.
And I want to try these till the end of my
career.
I think for classic ballet dancers this is
the end.
Maybe at 40 years old you can still dance
but it's very difficult.
But if you collaborate with someone, or music,
I think I can continue more.
But I'm also doing lots of things for young
talent.
Organizing workshops in Berlin, Europe.
Now next month I'm going to America
Boston and New York, taking 28 students.
And August Bolshoi Ballet where I started.
So this is my kind of roots.
As a ballerina
we start at like 10am because we had about
10 performances a month.
A hundred performance a year.
In Berlin.
But in Russia we had more.
Maybe 200 performances.
Every day different.
Swan Lake, Nutcracker, Sleeping Beauty, every
day different.
In the morning we start with on and a half
hour training
Taking bar, doing some movements, bending,
stretching and doing this.
And after one and a half hours we do maybe
like 6 hours rehearsal.
In Germany it's very strict, we have 7 hours
working time
and if you go over they have to pay overtime.
It's the seven hours but dancing.
Our job is dancing.
So 7 hours dancing, or doing like 4 hours
rehearsal, little break, and then performance
and next day the same.
It's very hard, but if you get used to it,
it's normal.
What do I have left to talk about.
Everyone always asks what I'm eating mostly.
But I think as dancers we
Maybe mens eat lunch
but we continue because we have only like
half an hour break
and we can't eat so much, because we eat a
lot and can't dance again.
You'll get a stomach ache.
So we have breakfast and like coffee or Coke,
caffeine and sugar.
Keep going till like 5 or 6pm
and if we have a performance we eat a little
something
to get energy, and then we eat a lot after
the performance.
Very unhealthy.
10 or 11pm is our dinner time.
This is our food schedule, so to say.
Another thing is the point shoes for the ballerina.
It's very painful in the beginning
but when you get used to it you don't feel
pain.
It's painful but normal.
Then I have very big bunions so I can't really
wear high heels.
But you have to do with point shoes.
And men are always behind supporting the women.
You have to do like...
Gym, because you carry women which is like
50-55kg
It's a very unusual profession.
But on stage...
To make one stage, 2 hours, we practice maybe
like 2 months.
And you have to do the same thing every day,
one and a half hours.
Every day the same things, like hanging, and
this, and stretch
and then starting rehearsal.
Rehearsal is like easiest..
No, the performance is the easiest part.
And you smile and dance and go back and then
you die.
This is our job.
But I think these are the last moments for
doing live performance.
Also like Berline Philharmony, if you go and
see it live you get goosebumps
but now they're doing internet business which
I think is good and bad.
Because you don't get the same effect, the
same feeling as seeing it live
Live is live.
But I'm thinking also like now
there are too many visual possibility.
You get YouTube you can watch everything.
Night, morning, and afternoon.
This is very good, but I'm thinking live performance
business maybe in 50 years will disappear.
But I want to continue of course to try to
make new things.